you are the top presidential advisor to
president
former president Donald Trump on Russia
and Europe and famously testified in his
first impeachment trial in 2019 saying
I take great pride in the fact that I'm
non-partisan foreign policy expert so
given that context what does nonpartisan
mean to you
well it means being very careful about
not putting any kind of ideological lens
on anything you know that I'm analyzing
or looking at or saying about foreign
policy for one thing but also not taking
you know kind of one stance of one party
over another either to be honest I've
I've always found American politics
somewhat confounding because both the
Democratic and the Republican Party are
pretty big tents some of their
coalitions you know in Europe it's
actually kind of in some respects easier
to navigate the parameters of political
parties because you you know you have
quite clear platforms
um you know there's also a longer
history in many respects obviously I
mean there's a long history here in the
United States as the development of the
parties you know going back to the late
18th century but in the United Kingdom
you know for example in the 20th century
the development of the mass parties it
was quite easy to get a handle on you
know at one point in the UK for example
the parties were real genuine Mass
parties with people who are property
members and took part in regular
meetings and paid Jews and you know it
was easy to kind of see what they stood
for and the same in Europe you know when
you look at France and in Germany and
Western Germany of course Italy and
elsewhere here in the United States it's
kind of pretty amorphous you know the
fact that you could kind of register you
know randomly it seems to be a
democratic Republican I jumped it at one
point it's drama crap next thing is
Republican and then you kind of usurp a
party apparatus but you don't have to be
you're not vetted in any way you're not
kind of you know but they don't check
you out to see if you have ideological
coherence you know you could have
someone like Bernie Sanders on the other
side on the left you know basically
calling himself a socialist and you know
running for the the Democratic uh
presidential nomination so you know kind
of in many respects parties in the
United States are much more loose
movements and I think you can you know
it's almost like a kind of an A La Carte
menu of different things and that people
can pick up pick out and it's more over
time as I've noticed
um become more like a kind of an
affiliation even with a sporting team I
mean I get very shocked by the way that
people say well I couldn't do this
because you know that's my side and I
couldn't do anything and I couldn't
support someone for the other side I
mean I have a a relative in my extended
family here who um is a
um you know died in the world Republican
and on you know family holiday was a
book on their table said 100 reasons for
voting for a Democrat and I said hey are
you um thinking of Shifting party
affiliation then I opened the book and
it's blank it was pretty funny I had to
laugh I thought well there you go then
if there's just there's no way that you
know people can pull themselves out of
these frames so for me it's very
important to have that independence of
thought I think you can be politically
engaged on the issues but you know
basically without taking a stance that's
defined by some ideological ideology or
some sense of kind of parties on
affiliation
I think I tweeted about this maybe not
eloquently in the statement if I
remember correctly was something like
if you honestly can't find a good thing
that Donald Trump did or a good thing
that Joe Biden did you're not
uh you're not thinking about ideas
you just pick the tribe I mean it was
more eloquent than that but it was it
was um is basically this is a really
good test to see are you actually
thinking about like how to solve
problems versus like your dread team or
blue team like a sporting team can you
find a good idea of Donald Trump's that
you like
if you're somebody who's against Donald
Trump and like acknowledge it to
yourself probably oh that's a good idea
I'm glad he said that or he's even
asking the right kinds of questions
which he often did actually I mean
obviously put them in a way that most of
us wouldn't have done but there was
often kind of questions about why is
this happening why are we doing this and
you know we have to challenge ourselves
all the time so yeah actually why are we
doing that and then you have to and
really inspect it and say whether it's
actually worth continuing that way or
they should be doing something
differently now he had a more kind of
destructive quality to those kinds of
questions you know about maybe it's the
real estate developer name that's you
know taking a big wrecking ball to all
of these kinds of you know sacred
edifices and things like that but often
if you really paid attention he was
asking a valid set of questions about
why do we continue to do things like
this now we didn't often have answers
about what he was going to do in
response but those questions still had
to be asked and we shouldn't be just
rejecting them you know out of turn
and you know the the another strength
the thing that people often that
criticize Donald Trump will say is the
weakness is his uh lack of Civility
can be a strength because I I feel like
sometimes bureaucracy functions on
excessive civility
like uh actually I've seen this it's not
just it's bureaucracy in all forms like
um
in tech companies as they grow
everybody kind of you know you're
getting pretty good salary everyone's is
everyone's comfortable and there's a
meeting and you discuss how to move
stuff forward and like you don't want to
be the [ __ ] in the room that says
what this is why are we doing this this
way this is
um on this could be unethical this is
hurting the world this is totally a dumb
idea like I mean I could get specific
examples that I have on my mind
currently that are technical but the
point is oftentimes the person that's
needed in that room is an [ __ ] yeah
that's why Steve Jobs worked so Elon
Musk works you have to roll in that's
what first principles thinking looks
like the one bit when it doesn't work is
when they start name calling you know
kind of inciting violence against you
know the people that have a disagree
with so that was kind of a problem
because I mean often one you know I when
I was in the administration I had all of
Europe in my portfolio as well as Russia
and there were many times when you know
we were dealing with our European
colleagues where he was asking some
pretty valid questions about well why
should we do this if you're doing that
you know for example the the Nordstrom 2
pipeline the United States has been
opposed to Europe's Reliance on gas and
all exports from Russia you know the
Soviet Union since the 70s and 80s and
Trump kept pushing this out idea about
so why are we you know spending so much
money on NATO and NATO defense and we're
all talking about this if y'all then you
know basically paying billions you know
to Russia for gas isn't this you know
contradictory and of course it was but
it was the way that he did it and I
actually you know one instance had a
discussion with a European Defense uh
Minister first who said to me look he's
saying exactly the same things as people
said before him including you know
Former Defense secretary gets it's just
the way he says it you know so they took
offense and then as a result of that
they wouldn't take action because they
took offense at what he said so it was a
kind of then a way of could you find
some of the means of
you know massaging this communication to
kind of make it effective which we would
always try to focus on because it's it's
a kind of the the delivery yeah but but
the actual message was was often spot on
in those kinds of issues I mean he was
actually highlighting you know these
ridiculous discrepancies between what
people said and what they actually did
it's the the delivery the Charisma in
the room too I'm also understanding the
power of that of a leader it's not just
about what you do at a podium
but in in a room with advisors how you
talk about stuff how you convince other
leaders yeah you don't do it through
gratuities insults and incitement to
violence that's one of the things you
just say you don't get anywhere on that
well I mean it's possible
tough measures and maximum pressure
often though it does work right because
there were you know often times where
you know that kind of Relentless you
know nagging about something or
constantly raising it actually did have
results where it hadn't previously right
so there's you know the maximum pressure
if it you know kind of kept on it in the
right way and you know often when we
were you know coming in behind on
pushing on issues you know related to
Nato or you know other
things in this same sphere it would
actually have an effect
it just doesn't get talked about because
it gets overshadowed by you know all of
the other kind of stuff around this and
um the way that you know he interacted
with people and uh treated people
what was uh the heart the key insights
to your testimony in that impeachment
look I think there is a straight line
between that whole series of episodes
and the current war in Ukraine because
Vladimir Putin and the people around him
in the Kremlin
concluded that the US did not care one
little bit about Ukraine and it was just
a game
the trumpet was personal game he was
basically trying to get uh
balajimizelinski to do him a personal
favor related to his desire to stay on
in um in power
in the 2020 election
and generally they just thought that we
were using Ukraine as some kind of proxy
or some kind of instrument within our
own domestic politics because that's
what it looked like
and I think that he knows the result of
that
Putin you know
took
the idea where that he could you know do
whatever he wanted we were constantly
being asked even prior to this by people
around
uh Putin like you know Nikolai patches
of the head of the national you know
security uh Council equivalent in Russia
we met with frequently what's Ukraine to
you we don't get it you know why do you
even care
so they thought that we weren't serious
that we weren't serious about Ukraine's
territorial integrity and its
independence or or it is the National
Security player and Putin also thought
that he could just manipulate the
political space in the United States
actually could because what was he was
doing was seeding uh all this dissent
and uh fueling you know already uh in a
debate inside of uh U.S politics the
kinds of you know things that we see
just kind of coming out now this kind of
idea that Ukraine was a burden that
Ukraine was you know basically just
trying to extract things uh from the
United States the Ukraine had somehow
played inside of U.S politics Trump was
convinced that the ukrainians had done
something against him that they had
intervened in the elections and that was
kind of you know a combination of people
around him trying to find excuses to you
know kind of what had happened in the
election to kind of divert attention
away from Russia's interference in 2016
and the Russians themselves poisoning
the world uh against Ukraine so you had
a kind of a Confluence of circumstances
there and what I was trying to get
across
in that uh testimony was the National
Security imperative of basically getting
Iraq together here and separating out
what was going on in our domestic
politics from what was happening in our
national security and foreign policy I
mean I think we contributed
in that whole mess around the
impeachment but just the whole parallel
policies around Ukraine to the war that
we now have
confronting signaling the value we place
in peace and stability in that part of
the world or the reverse by saying we
don't care yeah we seem to not care it
was just
but I mean the U.S role in that war is
very complicated one that's one one
that's one of the variables
um just on that testimony
did it
in part break your heart that you had to
testify
essentially against the president of the
United States
or is that not how you saw it
I don't think I would describe it in
that way I think what I was was deeply
disappointed by what I saw happening
in the American political space I didn't
expect it
look I was a starry-eyed immigrant I
came to the United States with all of
these expectations of what the place
would be I'd already been disabused of
you know some of the
um let's just say Rosie uh perspectives
are held in the United States I'd been
shocked by uh the depths of
racial
problems it doesn't even sum up the
problems we have in the United States I
mean I I couldn't get my head around it
when I first came I mean I'd read about
you know slavery in American history but
I hadn't fully fathomed you know really
the kind of the way that was ripping
apart the United States I mean I had to
read Alex's you know to talk Phil and
he'd commented on this and it obviously
hadn't you know kind of changed to the
expect the way that one would expect all
this time you know from the 18th you
know Century onwards so that was kind of
one thing that you know that I realized
the Civil Rights uh movement and all of
these you know acts of expansion of
suffrage and everything else were
imperfect at best you know and I was
born in 65 the same same time as the
Civil Rights Act it was a heck of a long
way still to go so I wasn't let's just
say you know as
Starry Eyed about everything has had
been before but I really saw an
incredible competence and
professionalism in you know the US
government it was you know in the
election system and the Integrity of it
and I mean I really saw that I saw that
the the United States was the gold
standard for you know kind of some of
its you know institutions and I worked
in the National Intelligence Council and
I'd seen the way that the United States
had tried to address the problems that
it had um at first and it was just all
botched uh analysis of Iraq and this
terrible strategic blunder of
um honestly a crime in my view of
invading Iraq and but the way that
people were trying to to deal with that
in the aftermath I mean I went into the
National Intelligence Council and the
dni the director of The Office of the
Director of National Intelligence when
they were coming to terms of what had
gone wrong in the whole analysis about
Iraq in 2003 you know in the whole work
of people trying to pull together after
9 11 and to learn all of the lessons
from all of this and I saw you know just
really genuine striving and deliberation
about what had gone wrong what lesson
could we learn from this and then
suddenly I found myself in this I
couldn't redescribe another word it's
totally crazy locking glass thinking of
you know Alice in Wonderland Alice
Through the Looking Glass version
of American politics
I mean I'd seen everything starting to
unravel over a kind of a period of time
before I'd been asked to be in the
administration but I did not expect it
to be that bad I honestly didn't
I mean I had been warned you know by
people that this was you know kind of
really a very serious term that the
United States had taken but I really
thought that National Security would
still be uppermost in people's minds and
it was when a lot of the people that I
work with but what I found you know if
you want to use that in a term of
heartbreaking was the way in which all
of these principles
but I'd uh really bought into and tried
to uphold in the United States uh
government and then the things that we
were trying to do with me and my
colleagues was just being thrown out the
window
and that you know I would have to step
up
in defense of them and in defense of my
colleagues who were being lambasted and
you know criticized and given death
threats were actually standing up and
doing their own jobs in particular on
the topic of Ukraine uh not just on
Ukraine but a national security overall
so I mean I'd gone through this whole
period even before we got to that point
I'm seeing non-partisan government
officials being attacked from all sides
left and right and but especially the
right and being basically accused of
being partisan hacks in a deep State yes
coup plotters you know you name it
they're um
patriotism being questioned as well I
know a lot of people I work with in
government like myself naturalized
Americans a lot of them are immigrants
many were refugees and many people had
fought and and was uh on behalf of the
United States and Iraq and Afghanistan
being blown up and you know they put
their lives on the line they'd put their
family lives on the line you know
because they believed in America and
they were just they were reflections of
Americans from all kinds of works of
works of life is what really made you
know that cliche of America great it
wasn't you know whatever it was it was
being you know banded around in these
crude crass political terms it was just
the strength of an incredible set of
people who've come together from all
kinds of places and decided that they're
going to make a go of it and that
they're going to you know try to work
towards the whole bit of idea of the
Preamble of the Constitution towards a
more perfect union and I you know I saw
people doing that every single day
despite all of the things that they
could criticize about the United States
still believing in what they were doing
and believing in the promise of the
country which is what I felt like and
then here we were people would just
treating it like a game and they were
treating people like dirt and they were
just playing games with people's lives I
mean we all had death threats you know
people's you know whole careers which
were not just careers for their own
self-aggrandizement but for careers of
Public Service trying to give something
back were being shattered
and I've found you know I just thought
to myself I'm not gonna let that happen
because you know I've come from well
they're going to send me back to Bishop
Auckland in County Durham fine I'm
totally fine to go back you know because
I could do something back there but I'm
not going to let this happen I've made
this choice to come to America I'm all
in
and and these guys are just behaving
like a bunch of idiots and the ruining
us you know they're ruining it for
everybody so the personal attacks and
uncompetent hard-working passionate
people who have loved what they do in
their heart similar stuff I've seen
for virologists and biologists so
colleagues basically scientists in the
time of covid when there's a bunch of
cynicism and there was just personal
attacks including death threats on uh
people that's that you know work on
viruses work yeah are they going around
you know but basically
um with protective gear on in case
somebody shoots them in the street don't
just upset